we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day take a listen to what
this caller asks david how in the hell
can the far-right be both pro-israel and
anti-semitic this is absolutely nonsense
yeah so this is an interesting question
this is interesting by definition if you
don't think being anti-israel is
anti-semitic then by its inverse it's
possible to be pro-israel and to also be
anti-semitic and we've talked about
American evangelical Christian support
for Israel these are people who are
support quote supporters of Israel but
they Harbor a ton of anti-semitic views
they don't support Israel because they
think it's you know a great place for
the Jews or whatever they support Israel
because they believe that supporting
Israel and Jews going to Israel will
cause the second coming of Christ and
the return of their Messiah right in and
in some of these Second Coming stories
when Jesus comes back the the Jews died
or all but some specific number of the
Jews died sometimes it's like I think
144,000 Jews that survived everybody
else dies there's other examples as well
so there is no shortage of pro-israel
anti-semitic people that are out there
and American evangelical Christians are
just one example we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today sign up and get
access @ww join pakman.com